the biggest challenge is it's
interesting being a really what's
considered a local group but with a
national profile because we're not
supposed to be doing some of the things
that we're doing and I think on some
level it's um you know and actually
being a black female leader isn't always
the easiest thing to be cuz I'm we've
got some really tremendous beautiful
attention but it's a the biggest thing
is that our the work that we've done in
the South Bronx actually should be
replicated all over the place and you
know what we're dealing with sometimes
is that because it only can work in the
South Bronx and like no that's not true
if they can work in the South Bronx it
could work anywhere else frankly Adam
but making sure that that that you know
understand that poor people you know
really should and could be a part of
their own future development it's it's
kind of a crazy kind of thing for people
to recognize letting people like I'm
from one of these communities and I
don't have a great environment I don't
have a good environmental background at
all I said we saw a project problem and
wanted to help fix it and so but I think
I've got enough Street cadential zand
enough experience right now but it is
difficult you know being in the
situation some time